it is a disappointing start for nasa's
multi-billion dollar artemis luna
mission the u.s space agency has had to
cancel today's moon rocket launch due to
technical issues
now this is the scene at cape canaveral
in florida where the rocket and its
unmanned capsule are still sitting on
the launch pad liftoff has been put on
hold because of a temperature issue with
one of the four engines earlier fueling
was paused when a potential leak was
detected and the weather has also been
an issue with thunderstorms causing
delays
so another slot now has to be found for
the launch of the artemis test flight
and nasa's most ambitious moon mission
in half a century
nasa hopes this rocket will mark the
start of a new era
venturing deeper into space
returning to the moon and traveling to
near-earth asteroids
the u.s built space launch system will
get its first fully extraterrestrial
test
europe is responsible for the service
module for the orion spaceship
the module will supply the astronaut's
capsule with air power and propulsion
until now nasa has only developed such
mission-critical components in the u.s
the new rocket must be capable of
handling crude missions so dummies have
been used during testing
the figures measure exposure to lunar
radiation and the effectiveness of
spacesuits
once in low orbit the upper stage should
set orion on course for the moon
some four days after launch orion should
reach the moon
the european service module will fire
its engine several times to set the
spaceship into orbit
orion should then circle the moon for
six days in an elliptical orbit
20 days from launch the spaceship will
again fire its engines to return to
earth
first facing the challenge of re-entry
into the atmosphere at forty thousand
kilometers an hour
the heat shield will have to withstand
temperatures of 2400 degrees celsius
parachutes will open at seven kilometers
above the earth's surface to slow the
capsule for a controlled splashdown
if all goes to plan the first astronauts
will soon be taking off destination moon
the three americans and one canadian
will circle the earth satellite just
like the crew of the apollo 8 in
december 1968
and the scheduled date for their
historic mission
the summer of 2023.
[Music]
and for more we can speak to rauf
densing the director of operations at
the european space agency and he joins
us from damsdat in germany welcome to dw
now the build up to launch hasn't quite
gone to plan how common is a delay a
cancellation like this
um well
let's
consider that a large number of things
have to work at the same time it's so
complex
that uh stuff like this can perfectly
happen so
let's hope that on the backup launch
date
which the best of my knowledge will be
the 2nd of september this week friday
let's hope that things go better let's
hope that the better is favorable and
let's hope that a little glitch that was
observed today can be
can be fixed until then
but this is now subject to
investigations uh post-scrub
investigations that would have to be
done um what is the extent of the issue
that we have seen and
then i suppose
in due time nasa will announce the new
launch date
okay now when it does eventually happen
hopefully this test flight
will take six weeks what will happen on
that flight in those in that time
well this is a test flight for a human
mission to the moon
so
never ever before has a human-rated
mission gone so far away from earth
it will go to a distance up to 500 000
kilometers
uh so it will orbit
around the moon a couple times so life
support systems
will be thoroughly tested so to make
sure that it's fit
for human exploration
and also the flight paths so all the
details will be
thoroughly tested also along with the
mission
will be a couple of small satellites
cubesats uh with all kinds of uh sensors
uh so they will fly to the moon that
will fly to uh laura's orbit they will
fly even uh to
to an asteroid propelled with a solar
sail
so it's a very very complex mission
design
and
now imagine
what are the limitations of the launch
window so today we had for example the
two hour launch industry today
and
and this is because they want to land
during daytime
back on earth and they don't want to
land anywhere they want to land
off the coast of kali california putting
very
tight constraints also on the road
it's just an extraordinary complexity
can i ask you nasa is saying that the
moon is a stepping stone a testing
ground for a mission to mars can you
explain to us why is the moon so crucial
in preparing for an eventual mission to
mars
well i guess
we have gained a lot of experience in
the international space station of
flying humans
in space and around earth so the next
level of complexity would be the moon
we have been there humans have been
there
some decades ago 50 some years ago
and uh so we need to learn again to fly
to the moon and uh flying to the mars is
a totally different story this will not
be a matter of space this will be a
matter of months to get there
and
so let's also consider
the moon is always close to us it's
always within say like some 300 000
kilometers let's say on uh on average
mass is much farther away
and
to mass to begin with you can only
launch
about every other years
so and this is because of the relative
constellation
between earth and mass so mass in the
worst case scenario can be on the on the
other side of the sun so
and
it's very very far away and then there
are constellations where
mass and earth are very close
so putting tight limitations
on channels to mask and therefore i
think they would be well advised
to try things out as the moon first
alright if anything we'll have to leave
it there density director of operations
at the european space agency thanks so
much for speaking with us